press conference she was very composed
very experienced she did that at the
state department had the answers
and had cordial questions not overall
easy but cordial this is the way it
should have been for four years
president trump not one day did any of
his press secretaries have that tone
meanwhile let's bring in charlie kirk
founder and president of turning point
usa and geraldo rivera needs no
introduction so i will not give him one
geraldo what did you think so far of the
tone what a difference
well the the press was definitely more
gracious to her than ever they were to
any of uh president trump's press
secretaries
but brian i have to say the 800 pound
gorilla in that room uh peter ducey our
own peter ducey
hit it right on the the nail on the head
you have a situation where
unless president biden stops nancy
pelosi
from pursuing this mad impeachment uh
we're going to have a very divided
country we're not going to have any
unity whatsoever we're going to have
people
100 you know stabbing each other in the
back it's going to be an outright civil
war
there's a good chance that if he is
tried by the senate he could be
convicted
uh by two-thirds vote uh i don't know
how the republicans are going to go
and then after that he could get by a
simple majority borrowed from ever
seeking office again this is
this is uh you know an existential
crisis for president trump ryan
uh raleigh it's a crisis too and if joe
biden wants to bring the country
together the way to do it is to say i'm
asking
uh senator schumer to stand down this
just
in you know this guy named john brennan
used to run the c.i.a cia
he says that the intelligence agencies
have never been weaponized to go after
another candidate
well he just spoke an hour ago let's
listen together charlie kirk
members of the the biden team who have
been
nominated or have been appointed are now
moving
in laser-like fashion to try to uncover
as much they can about
what looks very similar to insurgency
movements that we've seen overseas
where they germinate in different parts
of a country and they gain strength
and it brings together an unholy
alliance frequently
of religious religious extremists
authoritarians
fascists bigots racists nativists
even libertarians wow so he's already
seeing some type of foreign linkage to
uh i guess some supporters that were
here on january 6th
yeah well first let me say that uh that
was quite a different type of a press
conference i think haley mackinnani and
sarah sanders
are saying well i wish i could have had
an experience like that i think i heard
uh the clip of john brennan correctly i
don't know if he said libertarians at
the end of the day or not maybe you did
yeah that's that's quite a it's quite a
list and i'd like to look into that
uh further uh because that's quite a
accusation to be saying where all of a
sudden
that list goes from you know radical
extremist all of a sudden say
libertarians where your previous guest
would self-identify as
somewhat of a libertarian and so uh this
is going to be something that i think
the bidet administration
has said they're going to heavily focus
on and they should really be careful
when looping in 75 million americans
with some of these labels and these
descriptors
as glenn greenwald has said on this
network before
there are calls to try to almost start a
new domestic
war on terror almost a post-9 11 type
security state i think that is very
concerning and potentially troubling and
i think that is something that the biden
administration is going to have to
clarify
and they just had by the way this just
came across the center's contr
confirmed avril haynes as the new
director of national intelligence and
that'll be
on her desk guys uh this one a little
long gen saki i appreciate your patience
thanks for your instant analysis on this
historic day
appreciate it